well good afternoon uh welcome uh and
welcome to our our guest here today i'm
jacob hacker i'm the director of isps
and i've picked up this mic because i'd
like to sing you a little song no just
kidding um i'm gonna spare you of that
and actually i'm gonna hand this off to
eitan
momentarily eitan hirsch assistant
professor here at yale a resident fellow
of the institution for social and policy
studies
and also
a frequent media commentator on npr and
pbs and all other similar media outlets
bbc uh center you know the canadian
public broadcasting network um
and uh etan is going to tell you a
little bit more about the format of the
event um but uh he is
someone who's been working in the area
of political campaigns and in fact has
brought to academics an amazing resource
called catalyst which is essentially the
entire voting
public of the united states and one data
set so um if you could please turn off
your cell phones that'd be grateful and
aton knows where you live if you don't
so
and there's another note which is up
here on the wall which is that we're
recording this event so um if you
don't want to appear in the prominent
media outlets like npr and pbs um please
uh don't ask questions i guess right so
um so there are two hosts of this event
um first the scholar strategy network um
i'm on the steering committee of the
scholars strategy network and it is an
amazing institution it's it's so recent
that you may not have heard of it but it
already has over 500 academics and
academic uh and and scholars from across
the united states working on uh
important policy issues if you're
interested you can go to
scholarstrategynetwork.org
and the the goal of the scholar strategy
network is basically to bring good
research and thinking to the uh to the
to the broader public to policy experts
and i should say in the interest of full
disclosure
ssn as a whole does not endorse any
political party candidate or specific
policy position in other words it
doesn't improve this message but it does
approve this conversation um and then
finally i'd just like to mention isps uh
the center i direct the institution for
social and policy studies has a long and
storied history here at yale it was
started in the 1960s
and its goal is to bring the best uh
interdisciplinary social science
research and thinking to bear on
important
public policy issues
and
we have the center for the study of
american politics which is
the home for
top-level american politics research at
yale we also have a center on health
policy and a news center starting up on
inequality and if you're interested in
any of these topics or in the work that
isps does you should get signed up on
our website it's
isps.yale.edu we have a um we have a
newsletter that's put together by tori
bilsky here and tells you about all the
exciting things that are happening um
one exciting thing that's happening is
we're just about to accept our new
directors fellows and so you can go to
the website and see
what that's about but it's yale college
students who are interested in these
topics and who want to be
working with isps to develop their
skills as policy thinkers
so i will now hand off the mic to eitan
and thank you all for coming
thank you jacob thank you welcome
everyone welcome to all of our guests
thank you for being here for this event
about uh transparency and disclosure and
campaign contributions i just wanted to
offer a few words of thanks and
introduction before i turn it over to
our speakers uh thanks first of all
thank you to i should thank and disclose
our funders isps and ssn thank you for
um thank you for your support and thank
you especially to jacob for
supporting this this project
i would like to
thank pam green who put all the details
this together and it's very attentive to
detail and thank you so much for your
help in putting this together
um afterwards everyone should stick
around we're going to have a reception
uh where we can continue the
conversation in the back up there after
we're done here
let me just say a little bit about why
we're here as many of you probably know
um the supreme court has not looked
kindly on a lot of regulations of uh
campaign finance limits imposed by
states of the federal government
but the supreme court has provided
governments with some wiggle room in
disclosure what that means is that uh
the court does not see it as a violation
of first amendment rights to require
that
we the public learns about who donated
what to whom
how much
and so there could be some policy
movement in this area there hasn't been
any policy reform recently yet but
there's a lot of room there's wiggle
room and so this event is meant to try
to figure out what we should do with
that wiggle room
and whether there is um
a good reason and a good outcome that we
could have from requiring more
disclosure in political contributions
why are we doing this event here this is
not actually an area of campaign finance
that i've been particularly interested
in researching so far or that i haven't
researched conducted research in but
when jacob
suggested we do an event i was excited
about this topic really for two reasons
and so i want to tell you those two
reasons
the first reason is that this is an area
of public discourse campaign finance
that is very politicized very polarized
people have very strong views and those
views tend to be steeped in a in the
language of partisanship
and i think that's a shame because the
issues at play here are are serious and
difficult they pit two of our most
important values against one another our
value of free expression and speech
related to politics and to elections
with this value of having a kind of
election that has an integrity and a
clean election that we that we think
that we think supports our our
democratic values and these are both
kind of uh wishy-washy concepts but
they're both concepts that we talk and
care a lot about
and we can have a debate about what
those concepts mean and
how they uh they
they should you know which values should
hold more weight but um oftentimes the
debate we have is just uh about partisan
sides and so i think at isps in
particular uh we can prevent we can we
can present an issue like this in a way
that's that's uh
that we set aside our partisan
inclinations and focus more on the
issues and so
that's one of the reasons i think we're
here today another reason we're here
today
is that
disclosure laws in particular and policy
reform about disclosure uh demands
empirical evidence not all areas of
public policy are quite like this uh
that the debate between two sides um
one side can sink or swim based on
empirical evidence but this is one of
them right if we care to know that if we
think that disclosure laws are going to
do x y or z we want to try to provide
some tests for that and so there's an
opportunity here for empirical social
scientists
which half our panel is to
talk to folks who are engaged in policy
reform and the legal side of
a public policy which is our behalf
panel is to try to connect empirical
evidence and research with policy making
right
campaign finance is an area of law where
there's a lot of lawyerly assertions no
offense a lot of a lot of assertions
about right what it means that there
might be corruption or if campaign
finance laws are supposed to uh if
disclosure laws are supposed to change
the behavior of voters or of donors or
politicians the political scientists
among us want to say prove it prove it
prove what you think is happening is
happening and so by bringing us two
sides together the the the social
scientists with the lawyers we hope to
be advancing this debate and i think
that's right in line with the agenda of
isps and with the scholar strategy
network and so that's why we're here and
so i hope we're going to have a great
conversation our format is as follows
each of our four speakers
are going to talk one after the other
for about eight or ten minutes um about
campaign finance laws about disclosure
laws about social science research on
campaign finance and about social
sciences social science research on
disclosure laws and then we're going to
open it up for discussion discussion uh
panelist to panelists and then we're
also going to welcome
your comments so please uh
for the first part of the conversation
start taking notes and see what you want
to ask about and then we'll have plenty
of opportunity for group discussion let
me just introduce our panelists briefly
uh trevor potter here is a distinguished
actor who plays a lawyer on television
no trevor potter's distinguished lawyer
who has sometimes been on television as
his role as stephen colbert's lawyer but
in in real life he uh
is in law firm kaplan and drysdale he's
the founding president of the campaign
legal center former commissioner and
chairman of the federal election
commission
uh general counsel to the mccain
campaigns for president a defender of
the mccain-feingold bipartisan campaign
reform act um and one of the most uh the
prominent distinguished lawyers in this
field
uh heather gurken is from our law school
here she's the j scalia wright professor
of law author of many great articles a
former clerk for justice suiter author
of a great book about a
really neat idea for improving election
law called the democracy index
and and a wonderful teacher and scholar
next the third speaker will be ray
laraja associate professor of political
science at the university of
massachusetts amherst author of many
books and articles including the
forthcoming book money and politics and
party polarization in the states i will
say that ray la raja was
was writing and thinking about campaign
finance way before it was cool uh
in the sense that you know a lot of
folks
are paying attention to campaign finance
now and since the citizens united ruling
in 2010 but ray was was cranking out
articles on this uh ten years or more
before that and uh and and because of
that reason he is is uh
perhaps
is certainly one of the most
distinguished scholars maybe the most
distinguished scholars writing in this
area of campaign finance uh and last we
have david primo associate professor of
political science at rochester who has
written many great articles on a wide
range of topics and especially uh
relevant to our panel here uh david has
been
conducting really interesting and
innovative studies on the effects of
campaign finance disclosure
and with that i will turn it over to
trevor thank you all so much for coming
thank you it's a great pleasure to be
here at yale and at isps uh i'm
delighted to receive the invitation to
have an extensive
conversation about what i think is a
terrifically important subject so i'm
glad that you thought of this and look
forward to the conversation coming you
you are right that there are some
dangers of appearing on late night
television uh after i'd done the colbert
show a couple of times
the report
i ran into someone in a legal context
and i was introduced to this person and
we were having a conversation she kept
looking at me strangely and she said how
do you know so much about law
i said well i'm a lawyer she said you're
a real lawyer
i just thought you were an actor
so i'm glad to be back on real legal
turf thanks for that
um disclosure is a really interesting
subject to talk about particularly after
the election we have just had
i think it's fair to say that
historically uh disclosure was often
described as one of those mom and apple
pie subjects
where people were whatever else they
disagreed on in the political world
always ended but by saying but of course
full disclosure
um they may not have always meant it but
that's certainly what they said
today the situation is different and i
think discussing
where we are how we got here and where
we go from here is is worth some time
uh because it's an important and i think
interesting subject disclosure of
political contributions and then
political expenditures
has been required in one form or another
for most of the last 100 years at least
in federal elections
we had the publicity act then the
corrupt practices act in the early 20th
century both following
campaign finance uh or ethics schedules
then we had the post watergate reforms
actually the 71 disclosure act of the 74
federal election campaign act following
the watergate scandals uh we had
527 disclosure following the 2000
election mccain feingold
in 2002
and then
not an act but a supreme court decision
citizens united
in 2010
which in a complicated way i'll explain
actually appeared to extend uh
disclosure
so that's a that's a century of talking
about disclosure there's obviously a
reason that
it
went on for a century and continues
today
so first what are the rationales
uh and since i'm a lawyer i'm going to
look at it from the legal side of what
the courts have said
and maybe the political scientists will
do a better job of explaining the other
rationales but from a legal perspective
what are the rationales that have upheld
disclosure requirements uh in the courts
the first is anti-corruption the simple
idea that it's important to know
who is giving what to whom
who is potentially buying what
so knowing
the contributions going in in particular
but also the
source of the expenditures that may
elect somebody has been considered an
anti-corruption
rationale
going all the way back to the borough's
case in 34 and then
the seminal case on campaign finance
buckley vivaleo after the watergate
reforms where the court really for the
first time looked at a comprehensive
campaign finance
regulation system and talked about what
was constitutional and why and there
again they said that there are a couple
of reasons to uphold
disclosure requirements but they started
with
combating
corruption actual or apparent corruption
which they said can be combated by
exposing campaign fundraising and
spending to public scrutiny so that's
the corruption rationale there's a
different one
usually called the informational
interest
and
in buckley what the court said is
disclosure provides the electorate with
information as to where political
campaign money comes from and how it is
spent by the candidate in order to aid
the voters
in evaluating those who seek federal
office
it allows voters to place each candidate
in the political spectrum more precisely
than is often possible solely on the
basis of party labels and campaign
speeches
the sources of a candidate's financial
support
also alert the voter to the interests
to which a candidate is most likely to
be responsive
and thus facilitate predictions of
future performance in office
so this is voters will learn something
about candidates by knowing who supports
them it's kind of a coding system
and it thus the court says provides
additional information that help voters
make decisions
that concept was further fleshed out by
the supreme court in the baladi decision
where it said disclosure enables voters
to evaluate
the credibility of the speaker
and thus the credibility of the
political message
so the concept is you see an ad
and it may make a difference to you as a
voter to know who is speaking who who is
financing this ad
and it will enable you to decide what
you think of the ad so it's a the
concept is it isn't just the message
it's who the messenger is that is
relevant to
the voter
and then a slightly different view than
informational
which you might call sort of a
democracy value approach is justice
scalia's
and his theory is that active citizen
responsibility
is encouraged when citizens have to
stand up and be counted
and participate to be heard his quote
coming out of a case out of washington
state where the question was did people
who signed petitions have to have their
names be public he said requiring people
to stand up in public for their
political acts
fosters civic courage
without which democracy is doomed
justice scalia always has a colorful
way of noting things
so
that's the the court's overtime list of
why we want disclosure
anti-corruption
the idea of fostering civic courage and
informational that it tells voters
something
about who is speaking and thus the
arguments and the candidates
there is a balancing aspect of this in
the courts
going back to
the buckley case and looking at some
earlier cases where the court has said
that these public benefits of disclosure
can
in some circumstances be outweighed
by
dangers by hardships and that in extreme
circumstances disclosure will give way
to protecting people from hardships the
extreme circumstance the court was
referring to was a case out of the civil
rights era of the 1950s
called naacp the alabama where alabama
was requiring
the naacp to disclose its list of
members
and what the court found was
that this was an unpopular minority
threatened by the kkk and other groups
with actual physical violence and death
there were bombings there were shootings
and
you had a state
where the police were not in fact
protecting
the naacp and its members and that so
you had the double whammy of people
actually
prepared to engage in physical violence
if names were disclosed and a state that
was not standing in the way and
protecting them and so there the court
said
the naacp did not need to disclose its
list of members
so we need to keep in mind in the
disclosure argument and there is an
ongoing debate about which i'm sure
we'll say more
where the level of violence is where the
level of danger is to the speaker but
like everything else in the constitution
there is some balancing and while
disclosure is important
there may be circumstances
where there are exceptions to it another
implicit exception uh
in the sort of rubric of uh bad facts
like bad law uh is a case called
mcintyre
uh
the 1980s
where i
those of us in the field tend to refer
to it as the little old lady in tennis
shoes exception uh but that's a case
where somebody is was opposing a local
school tax
initiative or
issue
and put flyers under the car windows
in parking lots and was
charged by the state of ohio with
failing to disclose her identity on the
flyers as state law required and
basically the court said there are
circumstances where uh we're going to
allow
anonymous speech we're talking about
almost no money we're not talking about
an organized effort and we're not even
talking about a candidate election we're
talking about initiative campaigns
they then came back in other cases and
said but that applies to basically
little old ladies and tennis sneakers
because if it's a big initiative
campaign we're going to uphold the uh
constitutionality of disclosure
so
that's the theory those are the general
exceptions
where are we now let me talk a little
bit about what i think is the
philosophical dispute through all of
that period and then get to the
specifics of our current disclosure
situation
the
i think the philosophy the the issue
that we face here is
assuming that disclosure to candidates
and parties is generally going to be
required and the courts will uphold that
how much further can disclosure go how
much further can the legislature take it
uh
where is where do we begin to hit if
there are
uh the edges of permissible requirements
for disclosure and that really focuses
on what are are called outside spenders
the theory is you have candidates who
run against each other you have
political parties who support them
and then you have everyone else
known as an outside
interest or an outside spender and our
system as i expect the political
scientists will talk about has changed
enormously and with considerable
velocity in the last couple years in
terms of the degree of outside spending
that has occurred
so the question becomes if you're not a
candidate you're not a party committee
when do you have to disclose if i stand
here and say something good about a
candidate do i have to disclose well i
may not be spending money but if it took
money to get here if i'm an organized
group if i'm an organized group that is
focused on an issue and i start talking
about candidates if i'm an organized
group that focuses
all my activity on elections if i'm a
group
created with a wink and a nod from a
candidate and my principal purpose
appears to be to aid the candidate's
election where in this spectrum do
disclosure laws hit me and how are those
written so that's been
um
much of the the current debate in the
debate over time as the laws have been
written of what to cover and what not to
cover um
it started with candidates and parties
it moved to political committees uh
under the post-watergate rules uh and
then
we saw
in the 90s and the early 2000s a series
of again what are called outside groups
but individuals who wanted to speak
and we're looking for ways to do so
without
having to disclose their identities and
in the mid 90s there was a
small boomlet in speaking through what
are called 501c4 organizations social
welfare groups under the tax code that
don't register with the fec and report
their donors they register with the irs
they report their activity the year
after they've done it so after the
election cycle is over and they don't
publicly disclose their donors back in
the 1990s after a cycle of that
it looked from a legal perspective that
c4s were an awkward vehicle for this
there were tax issues about whether gift
taxes were due if you gave to a c4
uh the tax law required that their
principal purpose had to be
non-political and no one was sure what
principle purpose was
and so while they were being
experimented with
another vehicle
appeared actually it was always there in
plain sight but clever tax lawyers and a
lot of the
developments in this area are created by
clever lawyers who look at this and say
there must be a way so clever lawyers in
2000 said
rather than this cumbersome c4 with its
tax problems why don't we use that other
provision of the tax code called 527s
which are every political organization
we know they don't have to pay gift tax
if they're focused on federal elections
they have to register with the federal
election commission if they're focused
on a particular state election they have
to register with the states and disclose
their donors because they're what we
call pacs
but what happens if
they're
focused on politics at large but not one
particular level or one particular
candidate isn't there a little gray area
of arbitrage here where we can say we're
a 527
so we don't have to worry about tax
issues we can spend all our money on
politics we don't have to disclose
because 527s did not have to disclose
their donors and we don't have to
register with the fec or estate because
our purpose isn't to influence a federal
or a state election
well that worked for one cycle uh it
spectacularly worked uh in the spring of
uh 2000 when i was john mccain's general
counsel for his first presidential
campaign and we woke up two days before
the super tuesday primaries to discover
that a group called republicans for
clean air
was running ads of belching smokestacks
and pictures of john mccain in front of
the belching smokestacks and then it was
running pictures of amber waves of grain
and sunshine and pictures of george bush
and it was saying mccain was out to
pollute the environment
it was run by a 527 registered to a post
office box
nobody knew who it was it actually took
several days for people to find the
treasurer who was registered to the post
office box and camp outside her door and
eventually two texas billionaires turned
up uh who were bush supporters of course
and admitted that it was there 527 but
after that election
uh the last time congress has acted
overwhelmingly on a disclosure issue uh
congress passed a law requiring that
donors to 527 be disclosed the fine
print is because it's in the tax code
they have to be disclosed or pay a 35
tax as if it were a
corporate
tax but
that changed the situation for 527s and
we got back into the
c4 world we had mccain feingold
uh and mccain feingold came along to say
basically rather than worrying about
whether it's a c4 or a 527 or any of
these other things we think that ads run
in the middle of an election
should
disclose their donors the donors of
those people those advertisements should
be disclosed regardless of the form they
take and so that's actually what the
mccain feingold statute says
uh that anyone who spend gives to an
organization more than a thousand
dollars which is spent to run an
electioneering communication something
that
mentions a candidate within 30 days of a
primary or 60 of the general
has to disclose where the money came
from
it's a pure disclosure statute
that got us through to citizens united
and the court there
took what was a disclosure case
this group said we don't think we should
have to disclose
uh who gave us the money to create this
movie uh hillary the movie uh because
it's not actually campaign speech
and thus we shouldn't have to disclose
our donors
and the supreme court turned the case
around
it said
why are we arguing about disclosure
you're a corporation you are prohibited
from spending money on this if we decide
its campaign speech is the prohibition
constitutional and so
the court uh asked for briefing on that
and the court ended up turning the case
on its head
it said
you are not prohibited as a corporation
from spending money on politics to elect
or defeat a candidate to
issue public communications urging
people to vote for or against a
candidate because corporations have
full first amendment rights just as if
you were an individual for purposes of
campaigning however they said you do
have to disclose
and that part of the decision was 8-1
the
the court said
disclosure is important and the way that
justice kennedy restated that rationale
is is worth quote uh quoting
he said with the advent of the internet
prompt disclosure of expenditures can
provide shareholders and citizens with
the information needed to hold
corporations and elected officials
accountable for their positions and
supporters
shareholders can determine whether their
corporation's political speech advances
the corporation's interest in making
profits
and citizens can see whether elected
officials are in the pocket in quotes of
so-called moneyed interests
the first amendment protects political
speech
and disclosure permits citizens and
shareholders to react to the speech of
corporate entities in a proper way
this transparency enables the electorate
to make informed decisions and give
proper weight to different speakers and
messages
so that's citizens united four years ago
where are we today the 2010 elections
had a fair amount of speech which was
not disclosed the 2012 presidential
elections had an enormous amount 400
million dollars of speech where we knew
the speech occurred we had no idea who
was funding it 2014 we're still counting
but in some of these races
you had tens of millions of dollars
of undisclosed speech
so where did this come from given what
i've described as the history how how
did we end up where we are
a short summary because i'm probably out
of time
waiting for the hook over here but the
short summary is
a little-known federal election
commission
regulation
which the supreme court did not refer to
in 2010 and indeed my bet is did not
know existed but a regulation that had
taken the mccain feingold law that said
anyone who gives over a thousand dollars
has to be disclosed
if that money is used for political
advertising
in the election time period the fec
added a phrase to the law which congress
didn't put there that said
if the money is given to the
organization for the purpose
of making an electioneering
communication well it turns out almost
nobody actually gives money for the
purpose of doing the communication they
give it to a group they know is going to
do it but they don't write on the check
this may only be used for an
advertisement
further the fec then said well and when
we say for the purpose we really mean
for the purpose of a specific
advertisement so you have to say that's
the ad i want to run so the fec drove a
truck through the disclosure regime
at the same time that the irs was
overwhelmed dealing with applications
for new 501c4s and you've all read the
newspaper articles you're aware that
there is depending on how you phrase it
a scandal or something going on or that
did go on but it basically has left the
irs on the sidelines with more c4s being
formed all the time very focused just on
election activity not disclosing their
donors and neither the fec or the irs
in a position to do anything about that
thank you very much very much
i'll continue with heather gerkin
uh so i'm delighted to be here i i i'm
really glad when i got anton's uh
invitation he really had me at isps
because it's just an extraordinary
organization
period and it does this wonderful job of
trying to help academics connect to the
real world which is i can promise you
harder than you would think and i didn't
even know what a great panel i would be
with at the time
so
my job is going is to give you an
overview of where current disclosure
proposals stand and then i'm going to
talk to you about a new idea
that's been getting a little bit of
traction of lay
needless to say i think my part of the
program is the doom and gloom part which
is to talk about how nothing is
happening even though this seems very
straightforward so we have not made a
lot of headway on the disclosure front
in the wake of the supreme court's
full-throated eight to one endorsement
of transparency in the much loath
citizens united there are a few states
that are getting some traction in
minnesota for example past disclosure
legislation aimed at corporate
independent spenders california is
working on thinking about transparency
for the initiative process but at the
federal level the results have been i
think the easy phrase is depressing
supporters of transparency have tried no
fewer than three times in the last three
years to pass the disclose act and each
time it's time for repassage the act has
been shown of its more controversial
provisions in the hope of assuring
passage and each time the slimmed down
version has not been able to slip
through what few policy-making cracks
still exist in washington now i don't
think that will come as a surprise to
anyone who is a hill watcher i mean
things have gotten so terrible in dc now
that when i teach my con law students
about the separation of powers i begin
once upon a time congress passed laws
now the repeated failure to pass the
disclose act might come as a surprise to
someone who remembers the debates over
mccain feingold when one member after
another of the republican party stood up
and insisted that regulation was
unnecessary provided we had adequate
disclosure rules and so you might think
to yourself based on that
discussion that if anything if anything
can garner bipartisan support in
washington surely it is transparency
unfortunately virginia there is no santa
claus because this issue like so many
others in washington has become deeply
politicized thereby making it hard to
find sponsors from both sides let alone
enough votes to pass legislation
the latest version of the disclose act
does three main things
first it redefines what constitutes an
independent expenditure expenditure and
pairs it with real-time reporting
requirements which are much more
possible today than they were when
mccain feingold was passed second it
extends special reporting requirements
to certain kinds of organizations just
the ones you would guess corporations
unions tax exempt charitable
organizations and now super pacs and
finally it tries to address the problems
associated with transfers among
organizations which is really a common
strategy for hiding donors from the
public view it amounts to something like
an institutional shell game
now you can see why reformers cared the
most
about these reform provisions because
for years congress and the fec have been
playing the regulatory equivalent of
whack-a-mole with funders as trevor
described so whenever
regulations make it hard for wealthy
donors to fund politics donors find
another outlet to fund it so congress
closes the soft money loophole for
political parties and money goes into
issue ads and the 527s part that trevor
described 527s have now been displaced
by super pacs and 501c4s
these organizations either die didn't
exist or at least weren't major players
in early elections but now they matter a
lot and reformers are very very
interested in trying to make them more
transparent that's why the disclosed act
sponsors maintained these provisions
even as they gave up a lot of the stuff
that they'd managed to embed in earlier
parts of the act including some very
robust disclaimer rules shareholder and
lobbyist exclosure roles now there are
also some other proposals floating
around the hill
none seems to have a serious chance of
passing i will say many of them don't
even have a single join on them
now for those of you thinking there must
be another route to reform it's worth
noting that it's not just congress
that's been struggling on this front so
the fec
is often described as the institution
that was built to fail it has three
republican and three democratic nominees
and they have been deadlocking in a way
that they did not for example when
trevor was on the commission even the
irs the poor irs has ventured into the
elections arena and it experienced a
thumping so severe that you would have
thought that house of cards frank
underwood had arranged it so as as as
trevor mentioned ever so briefly the irs
has jurisdiction
over the 501 c 4s which are the crucial
source of dark money at this moment so
these include things like karl rove's
crossroads gps
and these so-called social welfare
organizations spent a huge amount of
money in the last few years but unlike
political parties pacs or super pacs
they aren't required to disclose their
donors now social welfare organizations
are allowed to do that because as trevor
noted they are primarily supposed to be
involved in non-campaign activity but
that vague standard left a lot of room
for the lawyers to maneuver and the irs
decided to sort of think about what that
meant and try to figure out if it ought
to establish some more rules about that
it received 150
000 comments more than for any other
regulation in irs history and they were
overwhelmingly negative
both conservative and liberal groups
insisted that the proposal would stifle
legitimate sofa social welfare
activities and run afoul of the first
amendment and some some thought that
while um uh
that was what the sort of protests were
i will say my quarrel with the irs
proposal was that even if it managed to
tamp down on some 501 c4 activities it
would not have made them more
transparent
so the question is where do we go from
here in this depressing state of affairs
if there's any hope for reform and i
will just say that is a big if
in washington then we need to find
something that meets a few criteria
first it has to be less controversial
than the disclose act and thus
potentially something that could get
passed because the disclose act has been
a resounding failure so far
second given that stalemates in congress
aren't likely to go away anytime soon it
would be a proposal that helps us avoid
the regulatory whack-a-mole game going
forward given that the odds of congress
returning to this issue anytime soon are
pretty small
and finally given i think that at this
point in time we are confined to what is
pretty small gauge reform
we should imagine this is a here to
their uh solution and what do i mean by
that the here to their solution
is something that may not be what we
want at the end it may not be the
perfect reform strategy but that it's
going to help us get from here to there
it's the kind of small gauge reform that
would make bigger and better reform
possible
so recently way gibson webb lions and i
have proposed something that i think
meets these three criteria we propose
that congress require that any
advertisement funded directly or
indirectly by a group that does not
disclose its donors acknowledge that
fact so this non-disclosure disclosure
would be simple and truthful it would
say something like this ad was paid for
by x which does not disclose the
identity of its donors and it would give
voters one would hope a little bit of a
shorthand for figuring out what to think
about the ad
so the proposal has some virtues it's
constitutional for one
even the much reviled citizens united
decision upheld disclosure and
disclaimers by an eight to one vote
the fix is universal for another it
doesn't make the mistake that we
sometimes make in campaign finance which
is engage in the regulatory equivalent
of whack-a-mole so oftentimes we try to
target the troublemakers du jour
while leaving space for other
organizations to emerge during the next
campaign cycle
our proposal
targets just like the early mccain final
targets ads and not organizations that
means it applies to any organization
that fails to disclose social welfare
groups and labor unions chambers of
commerce and private individuals and
better yet it would apply to
organizations that are built to funnel
dark money in the future
it is also less intrusive than any other
proposals out there which you might
think might be helpful in trying to get
it passed it doesn't mandate the donors
stand by their ad
it just mandates that donors who don't
stay at a stand by their ad have the
good grace to admit that fact and it
addresses the shell game being played as
donors funnel money through one
organization after another unless an
organization can certify that all of the
organizations funding it are transparent
it has to include the disclaimer
finally rather than attempting to sail
against political headwinds our proposal
works with rather than against political
incentives
we are not under any illusions that
donors are going to stop seeking
anonymous outlets for funding but our
proposal we hope would reduce the value
of the anonymous outlets by giving
people a reason to be skeptical of the
ad or at least denying the donors the
anonymity that they crave
donors are just going to be forced to
choose them they can fund organizations
that disclose their donors like the
political parties or super pacs
or if they want to keep their identity
hidden they can fund ads knowing that
they might lose a little bit of their
oomph in the eyes of cynical voters
political incentives one would hope will
push money into transparent
organizations rather than away from them
so i don't want to overstate things
because it is really hard to get reform
passed these days but if congress is
ever in the mood to do something a
non-disclosure disclosure rule seems
like the right something to pass it is
less intrusive than the disclose act and
thus more likely to garner the
bipartisan support that it needs
it is a universal fix one that regulates
the ad not the organization and thus
ensures that congress and the fac won't
have to keep playing catch-up as
political groups shape shift from one
institutional form to another
moreover it harnesses politics to fix
politics working with political
incentives instead of resisting them
in the long run the hope would be that
it will raise awareness of the dark
money problem by making it clear to
voters and at least making it clear to
the media just how many ads are being
secretly funded these days that is
nothing close to a full remedy for our
alien system but it is the type of
modest reform that might make bigger and
better reform possible thank you very
much
okay
so aton asked me to provide a general
overview
of what we know about camping finance
from the search and this was a very
bracing exercise for me because as i
considered the main findings i began to
realize that some of the same
conclusions reached almost 100 years ago
appear repeated into in today's research
and back then a scholar at wellesley
louise elvaraka wrote a book called
money in politics which looked at the
elections in 1920s and 30s her work
remained the scholarly consensus on
campaign finance and she served up her
findings in response to reforms pushed
by progressives at the turn of the
century today political scientists
appear to be doing the same things
in response to progressive small p who
desire additional reforms in the mold of
large p progressives so here's the
scholarly consensus about camp finance
i'll go through the list which dates
back to over i borrow heavily
from tom mann's excellent essay on the
subject and perspectives first more
money is needed in campaigns not less so
this is this is what scholars tend to
say
spending limits tend to protect
incumbents
contribution limits are easy to get
around and create other problems like
weak disclosure
money does not corrupt the process now
i know we political scientists sound a
little bit like chico marx and duck soup
saying you know who are you going to
believe me your own eyes
so um
so anyway that's something that's
controversial public financing is a
positive and partial solution to
problems in a system and effective
disclosure can promote an accountable
marketplace in campaign finance so the
beauty of this list actually is it shows
that political scientists have been
almost completely ignored for the past
100 years
and it shows the power of our profession
let me take each of these in turn first
money is needed more money is needed in
campaign not less a common refrain in
editorials is that the election is a
wash
in in money too much a shameful amount
well research actually casts doubt on
whether there's too much here
particularly for legislative elections
where news coverage isn't so good
studies show that increased campaign
spending
actually creates better informed voters
and you know what
voters remember ads especially the
negative ones
second it's not necessarily true that
things have gotten worse over time over
accur
and others today show that money the
amount of money in elections has not
really changed
certainly not relative to other types of
spending in society for example if you
look at campaign spending relative to
the size of our economy
it hasn't changed hardly
nations with large economies spend more
on politics just like they spend more on
other stuff
now a chief problem i would say is that
a lot of the spending is wasted
because parties and candidates they
don't spread the money around races they
just concentrate in just a few and yes
then the dynamic becomes arms race
and i agree that's a problem
um but turning down the spigot is
is is unlikely to prove the situation it
might even make elections worse second
point is related spending limits tend to
protect incumbents why is that
um because incumbents start with huge
name
name recognition advantages
and they have other resources at their
disposal to let voters know who they are
uh spending limits are no longer allowed
due to the buckley vivalayo decision in
seven years but before that they were
very much allowed
gary jacobson has shown that challengers
tend to benefit from additional spending
compared to incumbents and now others
have challenged this view but it seems
clear that you know you need sufficient
money to do well now the question is how
much
and what can be done to close the gap
between candidates and i think the real
another real problem i'm concerned with
here is that
the amount of time candidates spend
raising money is just unbelievable it's
all out of proportion to how much the
value of money is in elections uh at
least their election there's a lot of
diminishing returns
um but the candidates are obsessed
with developing war chess
three contribution limits are easy to
get around i don't need to show much
research here trevor just talked about
it heather just talked about it
um there was a brief period after the 74
reforms when things actually seemed to
work
but you know before that when there were
spending limits um contributing we had
independent candidate
citizen committees to elect eisenhower
or other politicians today of course we
have leadership packs super pacs every
type of pac you name it
here's something to think about with
contribution limits
some recent research shows that it might
be pushing the parties to polarize this
fellow at byu michael barber has done
research showing that candidates today
rely more on individual contributions
than ever more than they rely on pacs
sounds good right
well one problem is individual donors
are very polarized okay
pacs are not so here's the deal with the
devil
if you limit pac donations
you get polarized politics according to
this research but if you remove pac
limits you basically endorse a system
where corporate influence is heavy in
politics so where are you going to come
down there trade-offs here
fourth money does not corrupt the policy
process this is the most controversial
finding by far
not universally embraced by scholars
obviously
almost every study of roll call votes
shows that there's no relationship
between contributions and how that
member votes once you control for other
factors now
research acknowledges money works in
other more subtle ways money buys effort
in committees
the little things that happen before a
bill reaches the floor
if anything i would argue money buys the
status quo which is pretty simple in our
system of separation of powers
do campaign finance laws matter at all
in reducing corruption i mean this is
this is hard to measure corruption it
really is david is has
made some heroic efforts at this but i
haven't seen much much effort here much
evidence one thing seems certainly
certain the public certainly thinks the
money nexus regardless of the rules is
corrupting and there's no relationship
as far as we can tell between laws and
public trust in fact when the parties
were using or abusing soft money public
trust in in
institutions was on the rise
very paradoxical so
again none of this is to say that money
has no impact but i think it does but it
comes much earlier in the process in the
decisions about who gets to run
what they stand for and how well they
actually do
five public financing is good for the
system i won't say much here the goal is
to make candidates less reliant on
private money make the system fair
competitive lots of support in the
political science community for this we
need more work here because first of all
there's not much evidence that public
financing helps get new candidates or
the legislative process
the problem with most schemes that are
proposed by advocates is they're just
not generous enough and then they cut
off the supply of private money
that's just not feasible and it creates
all sorts of
weird here in canada you see what's
happening
i just read in the paper kennedy
one of the kennedys ran for state senate
he said he's going to limit himself to
public funds of course he's going to get
private money funneled through the
parties it that that's obvious this
brings me to disclosure i know dave is
going to touch some stuff here you know
disclosure is sacrosanct as a policy
tool but now it's receiving more nuanced
scrutiny
um
you know other forms of regulation are
controversial this is less so for
political science it seems more like a
pure good if it could help voters see
who's behind the curtain
holding politicians accountable
maybe preventing corruption so scholars
are starting to focus on good questions
what does disclosure really accomplish
i mean what are and what are the costs
we haven't looked into that how do
intermediaries like the press or
interest groups actually use this
information is it good do voters care
does it affect their vote um i know that
there's some research being done by
scholars at the wesleyan
media project that suggests yes
voters become more skeptical when they
see who's funding these candidates
but the problem is voters are ignorant
they don't have they don't look at the
information or they don't have it
so
with other regulations on shaky legs
you're going to see a lot more research
in this area there's some new proposals
i i like heather's idea
i might favor a more incentive based
policy like giving discounts
to
advertising for organizations that
actually fully disclose so you pay a
premium for being
for hiding your donors
um for not being transparent i would
also raise this is controversial but i
would raise significantly the limits on
giving candidates and parties so money
flows through them rather than
non-transparent groups bruce kane has
suggested semi-disclosure where you
don't actually publish the name of the
person giving them money but you know
like census data with demographics where
they are with industries things like
that um
actually the the one i like the best is
the onion proposed that uh oh i was
gonna say ackermann and ayers think we
should have total anonymity this is an
interesting piece of research um
so given that disclosure has become the
last stand we're going to have more
scrutiny
we'd like to know what would happen if
we didn't have disclosure
would politics become more nasty as it
becomes more anonymous would the wealthy
who are now reluctant
to who might be reluctant to give money
start pouring money and people who are
on the sidelines i think doug spencer
who's here today some of his work
suggests maybe not maybe under some
conditions it will
finally more broadly we need to i
personally think we need to move away
from this old paradigm of populist kind
of
big p progressive reforms these kind of
command and control
um uh sets i i don't think we're getting
much bang for the buck for them and i
think it's creating um a lot of
distortions that make things worse so uh
with that i think it's time to think
about a new approach thanks
david
hey well i want to thank um thank you
eitan for for inviting me here to
participate i i'm thrilled to see this
so many of you turned out for uh this
discussion of disclosure and to be
honest what's remarkable
about this turnout is that until a few
years ago
this wasn't really an issue that anybody
was really debating
um certainly not in in political science
there really didn't seem to be much um
to argue about um it was obvious to many
that when individuals of corporations
spend money on politics the public ought
to know this is a policy we were told um
that had lots of benefits the courts
told us so it must be true right the
informational rationale the
anti-corruption rationale that trevor
mentioned um so disclosure's gonna
reduce corruption it's gonna provide
voters with information to make better
decisions
and it's going to hold corporations and
other groups accountable for their
speech that's a reformers claim then and
continue to claim now
but as ray alluded to and we're starting
to see a lot more research in political
science now that's actually taking these
claims seriously these are claims that
had previously been treated as just
assumed truths they're just obvious
truths about the world
but in fact they are actually
empirically testable claims
and we're starting to see in the
research i'm going to talk about some of
which i've done
uh that and some of which actually
raised done and i'll talk about that as
well
that at best the purported benefits of
disclosure may not be as significant as
reformers have claimed and
the costs may actually be very real and
very damaging to the democratic process
and i want to conclude my remarks by
sort of talking about future directions
for research might look like and also
raise a couple of questions that i hope
will serve as the basis for uh
discussion and for q a which i'm really
looking forward to
so there's been a lot of research on
disclosure in recent years i'm going to
put aside two big categories of research
and that's observational research so
just looking at these big data sets
and survey
based studies
and instead i want to focus on an area
that is near and dear to the hearts of
the political scientists here at yale
and its experiments
so it's a little risky to talk about
experiments at yale because field
experiments one of the types of
experiments i'm going to talk about
we're actually
first done in political science in large
degree here here at yale um and
sort of they allow us to
change policy
in a in a manipulate policy in a way
that
helps us get at what the effects of
these policies are and what's important
about this what's important about
experiments and why i think they're so
valuable is that as heather alluded to
we're not actually seeing a lot of
movement in congress we're not actually
seeing a lot of movement in the states
there isn't a ton of variation in
disclosure laws that comes to us from
politicians so why not create that
variation in the lab i'm going to talk
about three kinds of experiments field
experiments
online excuse me survey experiments of
which online experiments are one type
and lastly natural experiments i'm
talking about a little bit of research
in each and show you why i think it's
relevant to disclosure
um so field experiments are actually
really controversial in the news right
now how many people have heard about the
montana
situation all right so big scandal
political scientist at dartmouth and
stanford had the nerve the temerity to
send voters information about judges
running for office and montana said how
dare you get in the middle of our
politics stay out of our elections
they disclosed
that they were doing a study but it was
in small print and they used the montana
state seal so field experiments are
actually really risky it turns out but
what's the goal of a field experiment
well the goal of a field experiment is
to
take
uh the real world and subject it to
manipulation so it's like an in-lab
experiment but you're actually varying
the treatment you give to individuals so
let me give you an example of a real
field experiment that's been done on
campaign finance disclosure you go to a
say you pick a set of of voters uh or
and you
randomly do nothing to one set that's
your control group you send another set
of letters saying that there are these
laws out there about campaign
contributions and disclosure here's what
they are
and you send another group
a letter that says hey you know people
in your neighborhood give money to
candidates and here's how much they've
given and here's which candidates
they've given to
and when you do that it turns out that
the people who get information that
people of the opposite party have given
to candidates are less likely to make a
campaign contribution
so one implication to draw from that is
that you might be worried all of a
sudden when you get this letter that
people are going to find out that you've
given to a candidate and you're not
going to be liked by your neighbors
anymore it's one potential problem
and so you're less likely to contribute
and this is actually supported by
another some work that ray has done
a survey experiment that ray has done
showing that you find a similar effect
when you manipulate
certain certain aspects of a survey
where again people are going to get
information that their their
contributions are going to be disclosed
publicly um so this sort of suggests
that there are these participatory costs
of disclosure that this is not simply uh
an all-benefit no-cost situation as
trevor trevor alluded to it at the
beginning of um of the event
um so that's the the cost side um and we
can certainly talk more about that in q
a what about the informational side of
disclosure um well there i think survey
experiments can be particularly useful
um so there's this claim that of course
it's obvious right that the more
information you give to voters about
who's giving
or in the case of heather's a really
interesting proposal that's definitely
worth discussing further who's who's you
know not telling you that they're giving
you can use a survey experiment to sort
of see whether that information is
actually helping and so there's been one
survey experiment excuse me that's been
done that's that's shown uh that voters
know really nothing about a candidate
and then all of a sudden you tell them
who gave to that candidate
they're going to be better able to
identify where that candidate lies in
the ideological spectrum so if you know
nothing about a candidate you know they
get a lot of money from unions chances
are they're a democrat
if you know nothing else about a
candidate and you know they got a lot of
money from oil companies chances are
they're a republican
but i argue in my work that that's not
the right question to ask
that what we want to ask is whether or
not the information disclosure provides
is useful to voters at the margin in
other words there's a lot of information
out there in the world
right there's this thing called the
internet right it has a lot of data
about candidates
and so once you take into account all
the information voters have does knowing
that this candidate got money from
unions really tell you anything useful
and the research i've done in ballot
measures suggests that it does not
so what about advertisements um so
connor dowling and amber wachowski who
had the good taste to be fellows here at
isps isps for for a year or two um have
done some really interesting work um
survey experiment work
looking at how voters perceive attack
ads
and they found that voters discount
attack ads when the sources of funds are
disclosed in detail so if a funder has
to list the top
three or four or five contributors to
uh to that
organization you're less likely to trust
the attack ad
or
if voters
or excuse me or if the ad
says that the candidate the the
organization doesn't disclose its donors
this is exactly the scenario that
heather discussed voters are also less
likely to trust the source of the ad um
and they're more likely to be
sympathetic to the candidate that's
attacked
um and i'm going to come back to sort of
the implications of that but i think
that's some really interesting work
that's being done
so that's field experiments and survey
experiments a third kind of experiment
now we're not going to go out and
manipulate the world um we're going to
let the world politicians do it for us
and so that's the world of natural
experiments we take advantage of this
variation that occurs in the world
naturally um and i've done this um in a
recent paper uh with a co-author where
we looked at a change in united kingdom
law regarding corporate disclosure and
how much corporations had to disclose
about their political activities this is
another area where it's claimed that
it's obvious that shareholders benefit
from having corporations disclose who
gives money after all how are you going
to hold managers accountable if
corporations don't have to tell
shareholders exactly what they do
well it turns out that when corporations
are forced to do this
their stock is hurt
they're actually the shareholders
actually don't benefit from this and
part of the reason is that um you can't
just disclose to shareholders right
you're disclosing to the world which
means you're disclosing to activists
activists who want to go after the
corporation um and so this sort of
speaks to how these these trade-offs
between benefits and costs um in
disclosure
okay so
there are a lot of other studies i can
talk about but i really want to get to
the to the q and a in the discussion
because i think that's going to be
really i hope it's going to be really
interesting
but i want to um just sort of close with
sort of the question that motivates this
this panel and that's where should we go
um from here um i think it's clear from
my review of the literature at least
that there is no well-developed body of
evidence showing that disclosure laws
have significant benefits
and um and have virtually no cost as is
often claimed by reformers
um and so i think it's worth sort of
probing deeper and seeing whether maybe
with enough research we can discover
that these effects do exist so in the
question of information
i think one important next step is to
actually ask in more detail whether
voters are actually better off with this
information
so again it's often assumed that this is
just going to be
the case
but again i don't think that it's
necessarily obvious so think about
something that's been a hot topic in the
world of disclosure and that is uh
disclosing uh calorie counts on menus
again something else we're told was just
obviously gonna help
people make better decisions when they
go to a restaurant you go up the
restaurant on the big board you see the
calorie count you say my god that's a
tuna sandwich that is not healthy at all
i'm not going to get that i was
bamboozled by these people telling me it
was a healthy tuna sandwich well turns
out the evidence is very mixed that
calorie counts that are mandated
actually help people make better
decisions
and you know is democracy actually
better off with greater transparency i
think that's the fundamental question
difficult question to ask not a popular
question to ask but i think an important
one to ask so let me give you an example
of another sort of result that came out
of dowling and wachowski's work they
found that voters were very distrustful
of messages from out-of-state voters
and if again the goal is to have better
informed voters voters who are more
educated about issues
is
playing on the fact that voters are
biased against out-of-state messages so
maybe requiring that to be disclosed as
some might hope um because these are the
the corporate interests if you will that
are coming into a campaign
right is that actually making our
democracy better to plan people's biases
um or
you know is it
you know playing on people you know if
people are going to discount an ad
because they know who paid for it rather
than looking at the content of the ad
again isn't that biasing people i mean
is that actually producing better higher
quality decision making among voters
and with that i want to close with a
final comment that's going to tie into
work that rey has done and to trevor's
appearances on the colbert report and
that's the media
so part of how transparency is going to
have an impact it's going to be filtered
through the media because i suspect if i
ask for a show of hands not many of you
will have gone on to the fec's website
and looked at the actual campaign
disclosure forms right maybe you've gone
on the center for responsive politics
website right and looked at summaries
but somebody's doing that distilling for
you
and you might think well i read the new
york times i read the wall street
journal i'm an educated voter i know
what's going on with just with campaign
finance well it turns out that people
who read elite news sources
actually know less
about campaign finance than people who
do not and that was work that was done a
few years back
and
it turns out um that
uh perhaps thanks to trevor people who
view and watch the colbert report know
more about transparency
than people who look at other media
sources so the solution to our problems
right is to have trevor discuss
transparency more often
on the colbert report make people watch
it um but seriously right there is this
issue of the media is going to be
filtering this and by and large they
don't do a very good job of actually
conveying campaign finance information
that's sort of another set of problems
that i think we need to deal with and
with that i want to stop so that we have
time for a q a
thank you all we have an embarrassment
of riches of
wonderful presentations and wonderful
ideas uh so we are going to have
obviously we're setting up microphones
either side and so if you have a
question uh
for one or more of the panelists please
come to the microphone and uh and we can
we can get started
um so please make your way to
microphones if you have a question maybe
as you do i will uh i will ask a first
question that that is to all of you and
that is a question about
uh thinking about this problem and
separating it into
big races and big donors versus
everything else so we know a lot of the
money most of the money is happening in
these big elections we know in those
elections there's a lot of parity
generally there's parody in terms of
money coming on the democratic side the
republican side um we also know that in
uh in the big races is where some of the
the big famous koch brother type donors
are are activated but what worries
people a lot i think is is what happens
in little races both because in little
races where there's as race had not a
lot of information there might be more
potential for
a really one-sided
one-sided financial contribution that
can tip things and um
and also in these little elections there
might be a lot more
small actors mom and pop shops that want
to try to convince the electorate that
hey you know this regulation proposed by
this candidate is bad for our businesses
and and we that has a slightly different
flavor than kind of large-scale
corporate sponsorship of money and so i
wanted to know whether um
any of your views are kind of adjusted
or dependent what kind of adjustments we
have in policy and law and political
science for for thinking about small
scale versus large-scale
i i think there's an enormous difference
between the marquee races
the obama romney race
and uh local races for
let's say retention of judges or the
county county council uh and and reflect
this as well i i think um
the amount of money that is spent in a
presidential race first of all is
is
is significant but it parallels the
press coverage
and the so-called free media so that
when people choose to go to the polls or
not
you would have to truly have slept
through an election cycle not to know
there was a presidential election not to
know the candidates and not to have some
opinion of them that is absolutely the
opposite of what you're going to find in
races down the ballot where you go in
and you think gosh i didn't even know
that was happening this year i didn't
realize this was the cycle for whatever
that position is i've never heard of any
of these judges i'm being asked whether
to retain or not
so i agree that i think there is a
dearth of i'm not sure if it's spending
but certainly a dearth of information
because it's hard to break through the
noise level
as well as not having the
the money to dominate the airwaves uh
you can't get through the press
attention at a at a smaller local level
and we're a democracy that has far more
political activity than many other
democracies do there are countries that
go to the polls once every five years
they elect their local member of
parliament and they'll maybe the mayor
and
then parliament elects the prime
minister you're
in a parliamentary system you're just
voting for one party but it's really
simple here we do voting all the time we
have on-year and off-year elections we
have the peculiarities of odd-year
elections
we have local elections on different
dates than national elections
it makes it very hard to break through
yeah i'd say there are three ways which
is true so one as trevor mentioned it's
judicial elections and local elections
often they're also non-partisan
elections so they don't have the
important heuristic that voters often
need to sort which is the d or r
democrat or republican so that makes it
even more
troubling
second is primaries where also voters
are not guided by heuristic and so
and it's very low turnout so money
is more important in those elections in
terms of moving turnout and things like
that so that matters quite a bit and the
other place i'll just say small scale
versus large scale and this just really
goes to some of the things i think
there's an emerging consensus among law
professors that the
the full-scale um transparency for
donors of to above 200
is not necessary the the the the money
that you want to be able to trace is the
big money um and that the only people
who use the the voter databases that
tell you for people with small amounts
of money are their neighbors there are
students i see some of my students in
the room like all my students know who
donated where um on their faculty so if
that's not a actually as
interesting as that might seem that is
not a helpful heuristic what you what
you need to know is where the big money
goes um and so i there's lots of ways in
which thinking about small and large is
is very helpful in this debate
i think the answer i mean
i'll pass that was answered very well by
both of you i just want to add one i
mean i i agree that certainly the there
is a difference between small and large
donors in in lots of respects on the
other hand i
if to the extent that we're talking
about constitutional issues or speech
issues i'm not sure that the because
you're spending a lot of money all of a
sudden you have less of a claim to any
particular right than than you did than
you did if you're if you're spending
less money on the other hand you could
make the argument that the concerns you
might have about the speech are more
significant than the greater you know
the amount of money that's spent but if
you look at some some ballot measures
that we've seen in in this year um you
know
corporations and other interests spent
millions of dollars um in in these in
these elections and they lost
um so the concern that that except the
ones they won except the ones they won
but they but they do lose so the the
notion that corporations are just going
to come in in these local elections um
and spend uh and spend millions of
dollars and and get their way just it
just isn't just isn't the case um
certainly you know nobody's going to
argue that money doesn't help um get a
message across
but especially in a local election
there are going to be plenty of
opportunities for for citizen groups and
others to to get together and get their
message and get their message out but
this is where this is just one place the
people who mostly don't read political
science are incumbents so the one thing
that you really notice whenever you talk
to these guys is you tell them like the
odds of you not being elected next year
are the odds of being you know dismissed
from the pollock bureau very very low
likelihood they are terrified and and
you can tell them look lots of people
even when a big corporate interest goes
up against them with a big war chest
they don't need a war chest that big
their incumbents they're going to do
just fine they don't believe that either
so part of it is is not the the question
of what actually happens on election day
part of it is what they think is going
to happen and they don't read you guys
enough if they did they'd be calmer
about it and i think less likely to
react
got some questions here should we go
right here
yes hi uh thank you for coming here it's
very enlightening uh i work with a group
of students some at yale and some at
harvard columbia and other colleges
on this
campaign finance issues and
we have
somewhat come to the conclusion
that
that any chance of of congress passing
any kind of significant legislation in
this area is
remote uh because of
what everything what you all know
polarization etc and gridlock
and that perhaps
focus more should be um
on the agencies that are regulating and
enforcing
existing laws such as
the irs right now and the
c 4
issue and the irs does have the power i
believe
to uh to
to create significant regulations that
would require disclosure so
my question to you is
why should we not why shouldn't we focus
on the irs why shouldn't people like you
and also citizens
make their
opinions known and try to influence
these agencies to pass
uh
enforceable regulations
i mean i i think it's
good to focus on the enforcement agency
some of which are not doing a great job
but i really worry about the irs being
involved in any of this to be frank i
mean
it's uh
it seems like it's coming to their lap
but they are not competent to deal with
political issues in my opinion it's
hurting their it's really hurting
whatever you think about what happened
with the scandal whatever it's hurting
their reputation and i'd like to see
that
go back to its proper
place at the federal election commission
that's that's my but they are involved
right but i don't think we should and
promote the irs as being a major
enforcer of
money and politics
the lawyers might have a different view
on this but no i mean i i don't disagree
at all the irs is not set up to deal
with this the 501c4s and all of these
non-profits were never thought of in a
million years as being political actors
they're non-profits under the tax code
with this tax status political activity
was over at the fec or at the the state
level but as i explained what's happened
is that you know clever people who are
looking for ways through the system have
said that's an advantage we'll avoid the
fec and the state agencies and we'll
fire the irs because they don't pay
attention to this stuff so then the irs
gets put in a position where
it's happening
on their watch they have a law that
the law actually says for c4s
that your sole purpose has to be social
welfare and you may not engage in
political activity but the irs decided
in the 50s that that was a little
draconian and if you just did a little
political stuff you shouldn't lose your
tax exemption for a c4 so they said your
primary purpose has to be social welfare
so now we argue over what is primary
purpose
what counts as an election expenditure
all the rest of it
i mean i don't know how to get it out of
the irs except to say if you engage in
any political activity you have to
report to the fec
the problem there is that then you have
to deal with your question which is so
what do you do about an agency that was
set up to require a majority to do
anything four votes to take any action
and functionally three democrats three
republicans
for a long time when i was there i think
we had one deadlock in the five years i
was there that was i can basically say
by accident um now
most major matters are deadlocked 3-3
not necessarily because it's a
republican versus democratic issue in
terms of who gets fined but on the
philosophy of whether there ought to be
disclosure
whether the law should require
disclosure of the the sorts of things
mccain feingold says uh how far the the
reach of the fec should go and those are
difficult issues
but when an agency is splitting 3-3 and
literally unable to act legally it's
then sort of tough to say well take it
out of the irs and give it to the fec
because it won't be done there either
exactly
thank you for your question
anyone else want to comment on that okay
so thank you so much for the excellent
discussion so far um i have a very
simple question i'm curious what
happened to the republican party in the
10 years after mccain feingolds why did
they change their position on disclosure
all right um
you know it's it's an example i think of
practical politics first of all the
party hasn't officially changed its
position uh on disclosure it was against
the majority of the party was against
mccain feingold in the first place uh
and
though it was bipartisan in name and
fact
the majority of republicans in both
houses
voted against it and the party then sued
uh and bush signed it basically with a
gun to his head so
that law
was
was
seen as as
hurting republicans i'm not at all
convinced it did but what it led to was
a world
where particularly post-citizens united
you had
much larger expenditures by these
so-called outside groups than ever
before you had a liberation of
corporations and
chambers of commerce and other groups
but they had the concern which has been
noted on this panel which is the
shareholders may not like it
uh our customers may not like it our
employees are both republicans and
democrats they may not like it so there
was
for the first time sort of the opposite
of what justice kennedy thought which is
we're going to have corporate spending
but it's going to be fully disclosed we
had the legal ability to spend money for
out of corporations but a
reputational risk to them if it was in
fact disclosed
and you had these vehicles you have the
c4s the c6s where the money could be
spent and not disclosed so i think
what's happened is that the corporate
money has ended up disproportionately
in vehicles that don't disclose so from
a republican party perspective you're
saying
we're finally able to compete with labor
unions which always spent a lot of money
on turning out their own members and
corporations didn't have members they
could turn out
um now we're allowed to spend it but if
we have disclosure and the chamber of
commerce has been very frank about it if
we if you require disclosure we won't be
able to raise the money to spend to
elect a republican senate is what they
said back in 2010 when the debate was
about citizens united and requiring the
disclose act so i think it's become
practical politics
uh
at the moment the perception is
uh and this is born out in the numbers
i've seen in this last election
the spending was about even amongst the
outside groups between republicans and
democrats but it was very uneven in
terms of who was disclosing and who not
the democratic groups tended to be super
pacs that disclose the republican
spending tended to lean
into the non-disclosing c4 c6s so i
think what's happened is that it's all
politics is local this is not an
abstract debate it becomes very
difficult to talk about it when the
perception is one party will be hurt or
benefited
by
requiring
disclosure we don't have practically at
the moment it's also just a sign of how
much the law has dramatically shifted in
the last few years in a deregulatory
fashion so
the reason why it was kind of a gimme to
say disclosure and disclaimers because
that's not where the fight was i mean
the law was much more
on the regulatory side and so if you
were going to put your shoulder to the
wheel you'd fight about these other
issues now
i mean disclosure and disclaimer are
pretty i mean i'm teaching election law
i thought about only teaching
disclosures and disclaimers because as
far as i can tell they may be the only
thing that's constitutional anymore
so that's that's where the shift has
gone and so unsurprisingly politics have
followed uh where the regulatory side is
great
so in citizens united um clarence thomas
voices are like very unpopular descent
like the one eight descent that
full disclosure could lead to like
intimidation and coercion
and that could lead to like more on
democratic processes and teams like
david if i may call you david
um has talked about when people see
their neighbors not like um
you know contributing to campaigns they
it has like a discourages participation
in like expressing their own speech
through donating
and given that
you know political sciences scientists
have had a hard time proving corruption
and like the
the benefits of full disclosure being
like there's a anti-corruption intent
and there's a information intent it
seems that david has also i don't know
if he did the research but there's been
research that shows that on the margin
full disclosure doesn't actually have
this like benefit beneficial effect of
providing information to voters on the
margin does that give any more weight to
you know clarence thomas's argument that
there is this coercion and that it could
lead to more on democratic processes
i i mean i i i again i i
i do see lots of concerns about
disclosure being used as a tool to
attack
rather than to
um educate
now you could make the argument scalia
made if you know if you want to if you
want to have an opinion you know you
should you should stand behind that
opinion
but on the other hand
uh you know if if if you fear that you
know you're going to be ostracized by
your neighbors maybe you don't you know
want to want to you know make a stand a
strong stand on on a political issue you
know if your social you know well-being
is is more important to you or you know
i i'm trying not to focus too much on
threats of violence and so on because i
do think those are exceedingly
rare um but on the other hand uh we do
need to be i think
you know
before we even get to cost we need to
ask you know are there actually benefits
here um and there is that's been the
thing that i think there have been more
assumptions about i think even the
supporters of disclosure have
acknowledged that there could be
potential costs um but they've been
downplayed because the benefits are
thought to be so great um but but i do
think that there is a concern especially
in terms of targeting corporations now i
suspect a lot of people in this room are
not feeling feel bad for the
corporations they are being put upon
because people are going to go after
them
but but
corporations
need to be participating in the
political process
because
politicians want to regulate them right
it's not that corporations are you know
free to do whatever they want and
they're trying to somehow interject
themselves into the political process
you know a ceo that isn't aware of
what's going on in politics is going to
be in a whole lot of trouble and so the
notion that that you're going to create
a road map essentially for activists to
target the corporation just seems to me
to be sort of sort of problematic i
think i don't think thomas is talking
about corporations so much in his
decision but i think that is certainly
an implication of um of his of his
dissent okay but now we just need to
talk about the first amendment for just
one minute so um i completely take the
point about uh uh the way good
governance groups tend to overestimate
the benefits i mean they always it
happens in every regulatory arena they
want the attention of policymakers they
promise more than they can deliver um so
but on the cost side this is where the
rhetoric has just gotten completely
overblown blown so first of all politics
ain't beanbag um
and and and if if there are real and
genuine threats of violence there is an
exception that you can apply for which
groups do um if there's there's a
genuine threat but but consumer boycotts
is not the kind of threat that the first
amendment recognizes if you just
remember back you know so right now that
the case that is being cited is this
storied civil rights case where people
are being lynched right for their
association with civil rights causes
that during the civil rights movement
let's remember consumer boycotts were a
tool of dissenters right they are
gloried and storied first amendment
tradition and so it is true that
corporations may get boycotted but that
is what the first amendment contemplates
that they will happen i mean we've
always boycotted store owners for what
they said when they're a racist so so i
don't want to um
on the cost side there the first
amendment does have and our traditions
do have something to say about those
costs and so everyone would agree
violence everyone agrees with
intimidation but the rest of it you know
it's not clear that the first amendment
i mean the first amendment embodies a
normative judgment about what costs are
acceptable and and it cannot be if
consumer boycotts are a problem then the
first amendment has been making a
mistake for a century i'm not saying the
consumer boycotts are in any way sort of
problematic from a first amendment
perspective but the argument that
corporations should have to facilitate
consumer boycotts that i sort of take
that i think is more problematic well
but but justice kennedy says that that
it's important for us to know who the
donor is and what the position is so i
mean how that's a justice i'm not you
know justice kennedy can say what he
likes i think he's wrong so yeah but but
why should why should why should it be
invisible if they want to if they want
to spend the money and it's important in
their corporate interest let them say it
and let their consumers tell them
whether they think that's a good idea or
not
let me take a different approach to this
discussion i think it's a great
discussion in the question and and
a nice word for justice kennedy here
he clearly i believe he didn't envision
what's happened in the only four years
since citizens united because there
weren't super pacs when the supreme
court issued citizens united which means
they were talking about corporations
speaking in their own names and so they
were assuming a form of political
discourse which is
almost universally now not happening if
you go back to the bloody case i
mentioned
where the supreme court said it
overturned a massachusetts law that
prohibited corporations from spending
money in ballot initiatives
there was a ballot initiative it was
going to raise the corporate tax rate
the first national bank of boston said
we care about this issue we ought to be
able to discuss it
uh the supreme court agreed and said
there's no danger of corruption here
you're directly implicated by this so
you can spend money on the ballot
initiative but they were going to spend
money to talk about whether taxes should
be raised in massachusetts on them on
other corporations what the business
climate was so they were going to in my
ivory tower view of things they were
going to actually contribute to better
informed voters by having a discussion
about economic policy and whether it was
a good thing to raise taxes or not
that's what we i think justice kennedy
thought we were going to get out of
citizens united is corporations
participating and he assumed it would be
directly and they'd be visible so they
talk about issues politics the policies
how it affected them what voters should
do about
tax issues or whatever else but instead
we got this diversion
to
corporations giving to groups that did
not disclose donors who do not by and
large spend their money talking about
the issues that actually affect the
corporation it isn't that you see a lot
of direct discussions
about tax policy instead the money goes
into a group which hires political
consultants who say our polling says the
best issue is something else entirely
and it all gets spent on negative ads
and the only bone i would pick with with
some of what ray said is the idea that
negative ads produce better educated
voters
it depends on what the ed's about if
it's actually about a you know
is our health care system better or
worse under obama
that may be a very
useful discussion but when it turns out
to be did somebody uh
pay their taxes 30 years ago did they
vote three elections ago did they stop
beating their spouse
uh all the sorts of stuff that a lot of
these negative ads turn out to be about
to me the corporation's voice is not
being heard the issues they care about
are not being discussed
and i i think our
political discourse is actually worse
and not better by encouraging these
sorts of negative ads and those
statistics will show that the
it is more likely that the money will be
used for negative ads if you don't have
to say who it's coming from because then
you're not accountable that is why you
will see that candidates are more likely
to run balanced ads but an outside group
that
the studies now are showing has more
credibility because you don't know who
it is so you think it's some sort of
non-partisan group
is going to run more negative ads
real quick i mean you make the
distinction seem very simple but it's
not i think it's not that simple
who's representing the corporation i'm
actually not sympathetic to the
corporation's plight to be honest with
you but
but uh but i am what i am concerned
about is people uh average uh
participation what i've noticed in some
of my research is people who are
cross-pressured live in communities next
to a republican they're a democrat
maybe their neighbor is their boss their
boss finds out they gave money to a
candidate or sign a petition the boss
can do with one click say oh jane what
is she doing wow she's really bizarre
i mean those types of things are have a
chilling effect and we still we're still
trying to find out so
so what do you end up with you end up
with people who feel passionate you know
so they're gonna they're gonna give no
matter what but the people who are we
want to draw people in who are not
connected to politics yet i'm afraid
that some of this
disclosure of small donors and petition
signers is not the way to do that
great great question thank you
well the gentleman before me
stole a lot of my
question
in listening to political scientists i
kept saying to myself
i love full disclosure i would love to
know who everybody is that's giving
but the concurrent thought in my head is
risk
in
every campaign in every administration
that i can remember i'm 58 years old
at some point somebody got targeted by
the irs whether or not you believe it
started
where it started there's a gentleman in
idaho i think his name was romer
gave a lot of money all of a sudden sort
of came out politically and gave a lot
of money and he was raped through the
colds by the irs
look at the district attorney in
milwaukee
i don't think while it's not violent i
don't think any of those people that got
a visit from the wisconsin state police
in the middle of night
thought it was very funny
and
i worry about the irs
i worry about
enthusiastic district attorneys
when you put your name out there i mean
all my neighbors are great i don't worry
about my neighbors they're all they're
all professors at yale anyway so i don't
have four
i worry about the one that runs the
anatomy department at the medical school
but
but you know i don't worry about my
neighbors but what i would worry about
if i had a quarter of a million dollars
to drop on a campaign tomorrow wouldn't
be any of my neighbors
it might be
it might be the attorney general in the
state of connecticut it might be the
district attorney for the county of new
haven it might be somebody like that
that just decided
that
they wanted to make my life hell
yeah just so we've litigated now two of
these cases um one involving disclosure
both the case involving prop 8
disclosure and then the case involving
a disclosure of people who sign
petitions and when you go into a court
of law and actually have to produce
evidence of these kinds of things what
you discover is that the kinds of things
that people are experiencing sometimes
their neighbor knocks on their door and
says you know i think we should talk
about gay rights and so that's
uncomfortable but that is not a um the
kind of thing that i think we should be
worried about people lose their signs
sometimes their political signs on their
wand but anyone who's been in politics
and elections knows that happens pretty
routinely but so far there's been no
evidence and if there is evidence
of you know a state official using these
things what would you say to the people
who got a visit from the wisconsin state
police
who were coordinating information for
walker
who chisholm decided to go after i mean
what do you say to those people
do you want to i actually yeah i mean i
i
ultimately i think that the that if
there was
malfeasance there i think it will
eventually come out
um so when when the
my you know the irs is a little bit
trickier um because of the the rs
getting a little bit tricky but in terms
of the wisconsin case i mean i think
that that to the extent that there was
malfeasance that will eventually you
know come out and that if elected
officials or if if if prosecutors are
acting inappropriately
i have enough faith in the u.s system of
government that they're going to be held
held accountable um so i i'm i'm
more concerned about
sort of the the
the fear that the again is racist the
average citizen thinks that they're not
going to be able to get involved
shouldn't get involved in the political
process because now um you know there
are now these tools that the sunlight
foundation has created that you know
when you get an email you can find out
and like automatically figure out who
this person is sending you the email who
they've given to
that's like it's kind of a weird world
we're living in now where you know you
judge your email by you know who people
have given to which campaigns that's the
sort of thing i'm a little bit more
concerned about than than prosecutorial
abuse i just don't think it's it's a
it's a it's something that certainly i'm
sure goes on but it's i don't think it's
this massive um epidemic let me just add
that i think that the the kind of the
view and the fear that you're channeling
is is consistent with
thomas's opinion and seems like an
utterly minority opinion uh in the world
of campaign finance but does bear on or
seem to bear on um
larger concerns in the post-snowden
world and when we have europe demanding
a right to be forgotten and concerns as
data is so much more available that we
might
10 15 years down the road have a
changing view of
of
all the information about us that is
disclosed and the appropriate and
appropriate ways for its abuse i don't
know what that looks like in the near
term or what it looks like related to
campaign finance but there's clearly
this this sentiment that you're
expressing i think that that is a
concern about just data out there and
who's using it for what that we are only
beginning to
to really figure out
i i would agree that that the world has
changed significantly since the
74
law laid out the disclosure requirements
and
we haven't reacted to that in a policy
since
in 74 200
uh
was a much larger sum than it is today i
haven't i should have done i haven't
done the inflation math but it's
probably closer to eight or
hundred or a thousand dollars
um that was one thing secondly when i
got to the fec in the 1990s there was
always a line at the front door
because the ground floor
had the file cabinets and the file
cabinets had the reports and that's how
the press got the information you had to
go to the fpc and go through file
cabinets to look and see who gave to
people well we're obviously in a
radically different world where you can
tell from an email what their history is
you can use an app to find out what your
your neighbors have given
it it's clearly time if nothing else to
inflation adjust those numbers and
probably to think about other systems
heather mentioned and none of us have
discussed the ackermann idea of
being able to give in some sort of
a black box the concept is you can
support the candidates you want
and no one needs to know who you are if
you put the money in a
government-sponsored black box and it
gives it to the candidate and it doesn't
tell the candidate who it's from because
it avoids the nexus with corruption so
there's not a governmental interest in
requiring disclosure that that to me is
it may not be the only system you have
but it might be an intriguing way to
to incorporate it for people who are
concerned about disclosure while still
avoiding the corruption
thank you for your question
i i want to thank you all first of all
for challenging everything i thought i
knew about elections and the connection
between transparency and disclosure and
outcomes
um i do hear
in a gentleman on the the end
you were connecting transparency with
some issues of control
and
i'm not sure all values need to have
definite outcomes that they have to be
guaranteed outcomes i think of value is
there as a value it's a goal it's
something we shoot for
what i want to ask you about was your
views on public campaign finance because
i recently had some correspondence with
jack abramoff
with the idea of bringing him to new
haven to speak on the issue of public
campaign finance we have actually had a
democracy fund
here in new haven it's an experiment in
connecticut new haven's the only town
that's actually set it up
and even though abramoff in his
documentary is very clear
that money
generates corruption he's absolutely you
don't need you can stop all your
research and that jack abramoff will
show up for i don't know five thousand
dollars or whatever and and tell you
what he has learned
that's very sporting of him yes
isn't it but you're here for free yes
he wouldn't go so far is to endorse
public campaign finance
so i thought what are the options
if disclosure doesn't work if
transparency is hit or miss
if even convicted felons doping public
campaign finance is an option
when you dream in the privacy of your
minds what do you dream of that will
work
what a question that's a great question
it's a great it's a it's a great
question i guess the my initial response
is and this is a typical professorial
thing is to come back with a question
which is what's the problem we're trying
to solve and that's in some sense i
think tied in with the the transparency
debate um is is
i've been one starting to wonder over
the last few years you know what
why the focus on money
so if if we're concerned that voters
don't you know need to make better
decisions
um you know if larry lessig who spent
millions of dollars with his pack trying
to get vote get candidates elected who
cared about campaign finance and failed
miserably if he had spent that money
sending out voter guides
right telling people in close races
where their candidates stood on the
issues i would argue that that would
have been a much better service to
democracy
um for uh for for for for leslie to to
undertake now of course he raised the
money not me so he can do what he
pleases with it
but the idea that the problem is money
and that we need to solve money and that
we need to tell more people about who's
spending money and why
i guess the question always comes back
to what problem exactly are we trying to
solve and we've talked about the
informational rationale and the
anti-corruption rationale
but
there are arguments that that
transparency actually facilitates
corruption i'm not sure i buy them but
certainly those arguments are out there
because and sort of builds on the on why
ackerman in aries it's sort of argued
for keeping these things anonymous um
which is that you don't want
candidates to know who's giving to their
campaigns um so so you know i guess my
my initial instinct is is i'm not i'm
not sure because i'm not sure exactly
what problem it is that reformers often
want to solve
um so i'm sorry if that's a little you
know wishy-washy but i think that's sort
of what i'm sort of puzzling with and
maybe the rest of us must have a dream
they want to solve a problem that
they're not allowed to solve so i i
think the farmers want to solve the
distortion problem the inequality
problem um and the outsized influence
that that wealthy donors have as opposed
to poor people
more people with one vote versus wealthy
donors with one billion dollars you know
the sheldon edelston primary right they
want to solve that problem they can't
solve that problem why supreme court
told them equality is off the off the
table so they're not allowed to talk
about equality so they have to move to
corruption and then supreme court tells
them well when we're talking about
corruption we're talking about something
super narrow okay so now we have to move
to a different portion so the i think
that the clear-eyed reformer
only thinks it best that what you get
out of disclosure is enough transparency
maybe to get the reform game going for
the bigger
the big game that they really want to
hunt
but that's you know they have been moved
over the last few decades into an
argument that is so much weaker and so
paltry by comparison and they can't even
tell you really that they want to hunt
the big game right because they can't
tell you like we just really need to get
a handle on where the money is going so
that we can get some bigger reform
because no big reform is allowed to be
passed right now so you're asking them
to do something in some ways that um the
supreme court has told them they're not
allowed to do which is why i think the
the it has shifted so uh dramatically
they're fighting over something that
what what's left to fight about but
that's not the that is not the core
issue but i'm sorry go ahead well i mean
i was gonna say i i wouldn't even have a
i mean i have some public financing
schemes but i if i were going to push
something i would on the equity issue
i'd say compulsory voting
you know you know make everybody vote
get people to the polls um it's the
people who vote and don't vote they have
they do have different opinions
political scientists have been saying a
long time they don't but more and more
they do have different opinions on
issues and uh it's never going to happen
at least not
next 20 years i can't see it happening
because even liberals say you can't make
me vote um it's just ingrained but
i think
that would deal with the money problem
because you won't have to mobilize as
many voters i have to show up for the
polls
politicians would have to appeal to
those people
now you might end up spending a lot more
money on ads to appeal to those people
that's true but um it's going to change
the terms of debate when you're talking
about a different audience particularly
in primaries too
can i jump in
well
i my back was rising as i heard the
question addressed to or the
conversation dealing with what reformers
want
um i'm sometimes labeled a reformer but
i'm a citizen
everyone in this room is interested in
what makes democracy work so i don't
think it's the reformers job
to
try to fix the mess we're in it is all
of our jobs to fix the best we're in and
the issue we're trying to address is how
do you have a democracy where people get
information about
candidates and
are able to vote encouraged to vote and
actually requiring people to vote seems
to me like actually a pretty good idea
but the problem is how do we finance
that um and we are different than other
countries without a parliamentary
democracy that changes things we don't
have a broadcast system which is owned
by the government and provides free time
as as most of the european democracies
do so we have a unique set of problems
but it boils down to how are we going to
get the money to enable candidates to
communicate with voters and other people
to speak about these issues without
corruption
whether that is public funding free air
time requiring people to vote the basic
still is we all want the same thing
in a way that is not corrupt that is not
selling uh in my view access but if
you're the supreme court you say at
least you know not not selling outcomes
um
those are
those are pretty fundamental questions
that we've been struggling with as a
democracy really
since politics moved from being local
and people talking on
soapboxes to
requiring the expenditure of a large
amount of money to communicate with a
broader number of people and that's what
about
1870 or so i guess
let me just push one one point because
there's a tension i think a little bit
between
um
particularly
particularistic interest spending a lot
of money to get their thing done right
you have you have an entire one
corporation and you want to spend money
to get one particular policy done and
then donors who just want one side to
win because we're in this polarized
environment where all their eggs are in
one size basket and so their best
interest for whatever issue they care
about is just to have one side win
and
there seems to be we might have a value
judgment differently depending on like
what we we don't care about
one side just trying to further its
interest of the side we too care about
the particularistic interest this ties
into what you're saying about i think
justice kennedy's view about well a
corporation being outed for it's
articulating its particularistic
interest that outing is very positive
because it brings light to this
self-interested reason for wanting to
engage in elections
uh but for the the generic and partisan
interests
do you have a different view about
what that statement that's the point
that that ray and david were making
earlier about some of these studies that
are showing that individual
donors tend to be more polarized the
pacs that were referred to are the
corporate interests that want some
specific piece of legislation so they
give to both sides
because they're looking for an outcome
but the individuals want their side to
win they very few individuals give to
both parties you you tend to
to to give to one or the other so that
that may be the
do you
the you're stuck on this spot do you
want more individual involvement and and
potentially more polarized or do you
want the the packs and the outcome being
what drives it
we have three people left standing so
why don't we if you don't mind each
asking your questions and then we only
have a five more minutes so if you each
ask the question then we'll deal with
all of them together
sure see so you mentioned uh two types
of disclosure uh the disclosure forms
that are filed with
uh with the fec with the irs without
with agencies um and disclaimers the
things that would appear on an
advertisement either in the newspaper on
television on the radio
uh how should we think sort of
differentially about the the benefits
and the costs associated or or concerns
associated with those two different
types of disclosure that are part of our
current disclosure machine thank you
good question thanks for a great panel
uh
how do i guess i'm wondering what the
panel thinks about
the failure of super donors in the last
couple of cycles to have an apparent
influence so the tom steyers an american
crossroads two years ago totally failed
they lost every election they were in
save one for tom steyer those the donors
are sort of effectively known you know
who next gen is you know that it's all
time fire money so you already have
disclosure does that tell us anything
about what the impact of disclosure
might be more broadly and also ray i
don't think you ever told us what the
onion reform would be
oh yeah
to make candidates anonymous
i was going to mention it but i didn't
want to get confused
canada's complete anonymity we don't
know who they are
protect their free speech
without being punished
responses
uh so on the i feel i feel like i should
respond because those are both my
students i could talk to them tomorrow
um in class but um i i think that on the
disclosure disclaimer front the thing
that's really useful about disclaimers
is it goes after the the big donor you
know that it's right attached to the ad
so it's more legible sometimes to voters
um because they're not going to go look
up the fec numbers and it's also
attached to the really big money whereas
um disclosure rules sort of go from you
know from the tiny little donor where
probably probably don't need that
information that's not worth the cost to
the big donors where it's very useful to
have that uh information so i think
that's that's how i would draw the
distinction and disclaimers are harder
to get through which is why they get
dropped every time there's any pressure
on a reform bill but they do they do
have a nice feature which is their their
focus on the big money and they may they
may we still don't know provide some
heuristic for voters
regarding the other question
tom steyer did he lose
i don't know i mean he got his message
across nationally about climate change
and
if i was a democrat i'd be thinking
twice before in a primary before saying
anything
against positions he's taken so
you know it's a long-term investment
from he said as much um you know
i i assume this guy's smart that he you
know he's made a lot of money he knows
his odds and he so he must be thinking
about this long term
the other side of that of course is i if
i heard you right you referred to
american crossroads losing everything
that was of course in the last election
in 2010 they won pretty much everything
this time
so maybe the answer is you just you know
keep at it they would say you keep at it
you improve your game you figure out
what you did wrong and you change it
and i would agree with ray that coming
out of this election
both steyr and american crossroads were
winners in the sense that they both now
are significant power players in the
american political system dictating
policies
able to
at least get attention to the policies
they
they care about uh and that's true of
the other
major donors uh the major players here
the
what we're seeing which is i i i think
taking a while to sink in is we're
seeing that where we used to have people
who donated to parties you now have
people who are creating their own
political machines
uh
american crossroads more particularly on
the republican side the whole coke
machine which is
separate from the party it supports
republican candidates but it's not the
party steyr on the on the democratic
side uh some of the others
so we're moving into a world where
you're going to have these major centers
of political power
who are individuals by virtue of their
money
let me just close with a charge to the
students in the room uh for those of you
who are in my election law and campaign
strategy class
you uh you know that i referenced i
referenced earlier this semester a
contest underway to come up with
standards for making uh for determining
whether a gerrymandering was on
political grounds ought to be
unconstitutional there's a con there's a
contest you kind of come up with an idea
for uh for a good way to to understand
partisan gerrymandering you can win
money and so i think after this
conversation i would say there is a lot
of room for us to figure this out uh and
so and so if you have an idea about how
we can do this right a problem that
needs to be solved a solution to that
problem how we might test it uh there
will be a lot of people paying attention
and listening because uh we are we have
we know a lot but we have a lot to learn
as well and this panel has really helped
us i think get a long way in learning
and so i'd like to thank all the
panelists and thank all of you for
coming
you